we will begin building our database for
sunshine by defining our weather
contract you might ask what is a
contract a contract is an agreement
between the data model storage and views
presentation describing how information
is accessed the agreement in a contract
is implemented in a contract class that
contains a list of constants typically
database table column names that are
used to associate data from a data
source within the UI of an application
so if this represents the user interface
then the bottom table represents the
data source that is being used to feed
data to the UI each column in the data
source represents a UI element if we
search developer.android.com for the
word contract we see that there are many
such contracts to find in the contacts
contract for example we can see that
part of the contract contains a list of
column names and we can have some sense
of what the contact database looks like
it has a column for the display name
flags for the contact columns for IDs
that are used to link the contact to
data and other tables and columns for
URIs at Point two images associated with
the contact in sunshine our contract is
used to both create and interact with
our database tables which is why we need
to define it at the start of building
our database of course to create our
contract we first need to know what we
need to store in the database